sally ce matin je vous avais proposé sur
facebook un jeu pour que vous puissiez
participer à une mentalisation
directement par skype vous avez été tous
à la répondante marine ciric tort bref
je suis en train de plier les petits
papiers pour tous vous mais nathalie
reid ans c'est long j'ai pas du tout
prévu ce temps on the last
et le gagnant ou la gagnante est flou
lilou c'est bon flow a accepté ma bande
d'amis qui me gêne c'est là qu'elle te
bases mais t'es qui toi le nom de flou
je vais mettre de côté et je vais
laisser tout cela dans ce pot ici que je
vais ranger là-bas et si ça vous tente
qu'on refasse des vidéos comme ça et que
vous voulez rejouer vous aurez déjà
votre nom une fois dedans donc une
chance de plus d'être piocher au sort
bon on a flotté en train de se désister
en fait elle a peur de faire la
mentalisation je me rends donc content
que vous flippez le mentaliste est drôle
il ya tellement rien à craindre
bon écoute flou je comprends il n'y a
pas de souci mais je retourne chercher
les petits papiers nous repérage au sort
à temps bref et ont bien du brésilien
le gagnant la gagnante et julie lips
julie liszt qui je veux envoyer un
message sur facebook et qui j'espère
sera connectée n'aura pas peur aura
skype et aura dix minutes j'ai commencé
à faire tous à 20h45 il est 21h 27 et on
n'a toujours pas commencé la vidéo et
c'est tellement drôle parce que juste
avant j'avais pas vu que tu avais
répondu que que tu bouder sur facebook
je vous présente julie je dis tu habitat
et tu travailles au petit à petit et si
je dis pas de bêtises vous étiez venu me
voir en spectacle
s'il a été bien avec eux tu étais avec
eux via [ __ ] tu connais du monde avec
les places via la boîte vu la chance
mais je pourrais très bien chanté sache
que je chante très bien
sache que j'ai tout à fait les capacités
vocales de faire un concert je préparais
des cartes des symboles esp je vous mets
une fiche juste ici pour vous faire voir
la vidéo où j'avais fait sur les
symboles s'était déjà et ça je te
présente petite prédiction que j'ai mis
dans une enveloppe
alors si je l' âme et oui j'ai pas du
tout pensé que tu ne vois pas du tout ce
que je fais là en dessous
alors écoute je vais disparaître pour
laisser place à mes mains tu me verras
plus c'est pas grave alors je mets la
prédiction ici comme celle bougera pas
et là j'ai donc quelques symboles esp
sur des cartes comme ça je vous fais
voir les cartes alors les symboles sont
derrière évidemment la course mais la
prédiction parle à tous les symboles là
toi tu dois tout voir c'est bon vous
voyez tout aussi c'est bon super dans
l'idée je vais pas te demander de
choisir un symbole parce qu'on pourrait
penser que j'ai regardé sur facebook ce
que tu aimais que j'ai fait des
déductions et que je pourrai anticipé à
l'avance la couleur que tu choisis ou
symboles qui tirait le mieux donc je
vais te faire choisir un symbole mais
avec une étape en plus une étape
numérique
l'étape numérique allait très importante
c'est une étape de correspondance ça te
parle pas très bien ça te parlera mieux
à la fin est ce que en prenant le temps
de réfléchir tu peux me donner un nombre
entre 1 et 6 mais en prenant le temps de
réfléchir faut que ce soit un vrai choix
c'est bon alors je t'écoute ouidah sur
le 2 ok tu as choisi le 2 je vais te
revoir quelque chose j'espère que tu
vois toujours bien et que vous allez
aussi bien voir derrière toutes les
cartes
il ya un symbole en fait les toiles
c'était le numéro 5
ok la croix c'est le numéro 6 le
caresser le numéro un
le triangle ces numéros 4
les vagues le numéro 3 et le cercle le
numéro 2 j'ai fait exprès de pas les
mettre dans le même ordre que j'ai
vraiment mélange et toi tu as choisi le
2 donc la carte numéro deux c'est ce
symbole là je sors juste du champ pour
vous faire voir aussi la carte numéro
deux c'est ce symbole là et je leur fait
voir un petit peu les autres ça c'est le
3 ça c'est le 4 etc etc
donc tu as choisi le cercle rouge
pourquoi tu as choisi le 2 2 tu sais que
tu viens de calais discrètement ta date
de naissance pour qu'on ne souhaite un
bon anniversaire le 20 février
c'est bien joué c'est très bien où tu as
choisi le cercle rouge et écoute je te
fais voir la prédiction je pense que
tout le monde voit bien ici et toi aussi
au caire ont écarté une seule carte
parmi les six à l'intérieur quand je la
laisserai ici tu leur ai choisi ah non
vous fait voir aussi cette petite
enveloppe d'affaires affiche toutefois
un temps assez étonnant à c'est un joli
mot merci c'est cool je range toutes mes
petites affaires
écoute je ne sais pas si ça si ça leur
plaît raza est ce que toi ça te plait
participer à ça en fait à une vidéo
comme ça oui
alors dans ce cas là je le ferai
peut-être sur d'autres vidéos participer
en plus
jean kita qui suit on sent les meufs qui
est dans la communication c'est hyper
intéressant ça fait participer les gens
qui suivent
c'est le réflexe professionnel je peux
m'engager je te donnerai les réponses
l'année prochaine pour ton anniversaire
merci à vous si la vidéo avec julie vous
a plu vous pouvez nous le faire savoir à
julia mois en laissant un petit pouce en
l'air
si ça vous dit qu'on continue à faire sa
démondialisation par skype je vous fais
participer vous le dites dans les
commentaires et vous pouvez également
vous abonner à la chaîne parce que le
mans table que c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an alors rendez vous demain
17h ciao
oui